Right Wesley congratulations an
important Victory and you surprised us
all with your opening choice and how
fast you were playing tell us the story
of this piece of opening
preparation oh yeah hi Christian thank
you well first of all uh what my
birthday yesterday happy birthday
everybody
birthday yes
you no yeah I'm 30 I'm I'm catching up
to you Christian
but uh yeah it it feels good being 30
you know you can make as you get older
you can make decisions of your own and
then you know become more of an adult
and uh you know it's more it's more fun
they said my teacher said before high
school was the best times of your life
but you know everyone gets older and
then I know I appreciate all the
experiences I had I'm glad to be
30 but uh very philosophical yes Wesley
well welcome to the 30 I feel exactly
like you Wesley just you know that I'm
looking forward to you know maturing and
becoming a full adult and making your
own decisions making my own decisions
what happened today you you you you
chose the line that Bobby Fisher play
Bishop
C4 oh yeah yeah yeah for sure uh well I
was actually inspired also by Fisher but
also by Magnus he played this uh a few
days ago against Vincent kimer in the
Club cup but Misha always plays the
nidorf I think he's been experimenting
with the win as well but I thought I'd
play this risky line because tourament
not going my way also the last few
months has not been going my way so I
thought why not try to play this risky
line then IED it very deeply but it's
very double edged and uh White is not
better but I figured it it doesn't hurt
to try and it's a new change to my usual
um my usual games which always includes
trading the Queens so Wesley how deep
was your preparation in this line where
did how do I what where did your
preparation
end well after e takes D5 e takes D so
this is so right up until this moment
before the move D5 you you you you knew
about this position you thought it was
even yeah I had very deep anal life
Affairs basically just the starting
position of my analysis wow but white is
not better no yeah I mean how fast times
have changed yeah like maybe 40 years
ago you play one4 and then you're out of
book but it's about six years ago by the
way
40 you play you play one E4 six and then
you're out the book
right uh but we we thought the move D5
was actually pretty mature did you did
you prepare against Queen A5 then is
that what I understand yes yes it's the
main line but uh yeah it's just a it's
just a I actually had quite a lengthly
discussion with my great opponent with
Mishra okay
after um wait is it his last name abim
Manu or is it Mishra okay I'm getting
confused
MRA okay I I got it backwards but anyway
I had a lenty discussion Queen A5 uh so
he didn't like the move Knight B3 for
black but he actually missed a crucial
part he just missed that he could just
take on A3 King A2 Queen A4 Bishop A3
D5 Rook A1 yeah and he may he could just
go like take and queen D6 I guess that's
what you missed as well yes sir yeah
yeah very similar blind spot very yeah
that the queen just actually has a
square of the pawns on
E5 it's good I don't know why Wesley is
laughing at you but yeah I mean yeah I
mean missed it like look hey man you
know you're on the same rating right now
yeah right right right maybe you should
play there you go um after D5 I mean
queen A5 we also after Queen A5 G5 is
just a dra Bishop takes G5 Queen A5 like
Queen yeah like Queen A5 I had to play
G5 otherwise I'm worse okay G5 and here
black if black want he can force a door
with Bishop takes Pawn on G5 I
see yeah takes Knight A3 but I'm very
impressed by my opponent because he
found all the best moves so like take
and Knight C4 and black just has forces
to draw
so I mean I was ready to draw at this
point you know because Mish found all
the best moves in the opening and he's
got like an encyclopedic knowledge but I
was very surprised why he played D5 and
here just an exchange down I didn't like
his move Bishop E5 but maybe there
wasn't anything better I don't know like
I don't know if black could oh there's
also an interesting line a bishop D6
which we also discuss he could play
Bishop A3
he could play bishop and then Rook
E8 A3 which I
underestimated and takes takes takes on
E8
uh yeah there's no other way to defend
the bishop fortunately Rook D E1 Rook B
Rook Queen d8 Rook E1 D E1 yeah Queen d8
H six and I wasn't sure what was
happening here I thought white is better
but I could be wrong
M where did King A2 look so natural to
me so I just played
it where did you feel that you had the
game more or less in your favor Wesley
more or less we thought once you got
your kingside going it was it was
winning like here yeah for sure well
when he played D5 I knew it was a big
mistake that was the I got very excited
yeah I mean he's got an isolated pawn
and then his b on B7 is
blockaded very I mean the bishop on B7
is very passive uh so I was very
happy but uh yeah in the game I I don't
think there was a way to save it for
black right although I'm not an engine
so your first win of the tournament
you're witnessing Fabby uh win three
games in a row your thoughts uh
with the tournament
ahead um well Fabby has obviously been
very impressive he's
gained uh almost 50 points in the last
10 months I believe so he's doing really
well I was very impressed by his game
against
Darius the other day uh he wasn't better
but you know fabbi is just type of
player who just knows how to play chess
he's a complete allaround player you
know he's very good in the openings and
you know he can just
he can just play chess unfortunately
so yeah I mean like some players for
example are very good at one thing let's
say tactics or the openings or
calculating but uh you fabbi is just a
very good chess player
overall and uh yeah as for me I just
take it uh a game at the time you know
TR as I mentioned earlier the last few
months haven't been going my way but you
know I'll just take it easy try to be
happy and relaxed and uh if it doesn't
go my way that's fine that's what I
that's that's happened before thank you
Wesley for joining us we're happy to let
you relax and take it easy we see you
yeah I will see you again uh where's the
action uh Christian as